[Music]
i see you go on cnbc a few times and uh
getting some uh verbal tussles you know
back in the day you and i used to have
some verbal tussles which i just want to
remind people of but uh recently you've
been asked about the vaccine mandates
and kind of choice versus mandates etc
like what's your general take
now that we're in kind of as you said
like a new version of this whole thing
and like how do you think business
owners specifically should be thinking
about this obviously with shark tank
there's a lot of small business owners
that watch and they like the show etc
when you talk to those business owners
like how are they balancing the health
stuff versus running their businesses
supply chain it's just a very complex
environment right now so like how do you
think about that how do you talk to
those companies
so i have been talking to those
companies because i wanted to get some
tonality of their policy and start
applying it to ours in the case where
we're a control shareholder i want to
respect people's rights to do what they
wish with their own personal health at
the same time i want to respect the
employees that work together and so
the way i think it should shake out on
private business you know this just got
tested in the supreme court and got
rejected
it the government shouldn't be able to
do a mandate to a private company and
tell them what to do the private company
should be able to decide their own
policy and indeed that's what's
happening there are many companies that
have made the decision at the board
level that if you're going to work
together in an office in an airplane in
a factory in a manufacturing facility
whatever
you have to be vaccinated now you don't
have to be vaccinated but you're not
going to have a job so you're going to
have to make that decision individually
and some people are going to make the
decision they're not going to get
vaccine they're going to go find try and
find a job where they can work remotely
in perpetuity or they you know a company
that doesn't have a policy like that but
if you go down the s p 500 slowly but
surely since we last talked pomp you've
seen many large entities put in place
including citibank recently that edict
giving people time to get their vaccines
paying for the vaccines giving them time
off to go get their vaccines supporting
them any way they can but if they don't
choose to get vaccinated
they lose their job and i'm okay with
that i'm okay with it it still gives you
the personal right to do what you wish
but it shows respect to your fellow
worker that you don't want to infect
them because really we're all in this
thing together it's been said countless
times and we are
but you know if you want if you want to
get sick right now you just go into a
room with 20 people somebody's going to
have covet and you're going to get sick
and if you're vaccinated you're going to
survive if you're not the outcome's
unknown
joe john what questions you guys got i'm
going to pull us a little bit closer
back to the middle of uh of discussing
digital assets
kevin they don't like that i like
talking about you know important topics
they like to talk about
i'm just saying he's here for a reason
we're gonna let him uh we're gonna bring
him right back in go ahead um
let's talk about some of the investments
you're making i know that you've been
public about kind of the the specific
assets that you're investing in and it's
pretty diversified portfolio you've got
bitcoin ethereum solana polygon and
others
i want to talk about just quickly if you
can run through your general framework
of how you determine where you're going
to allocate capital
so
i've come to the conclusion on all all
things digital the best way to look at
it and i've said this several times
bitcoin is not a coin it's software what
i do is i say to myself i've seen this
movie before i was an investor in
software
you know engineers 22 years ago at the
learning company when we made
educational software
so the way i used to do it then is the
way i'm doing it now i'm very lucky guy
i can make a phone call and it always
gets returned that's the whole shark
tank thing and i get all that but if i
want to invest in polygon i want to meet
the engineering team which i did in
dubai i called him up met him met the
team
heard their vision of what they're doing
looked at the economic reality of the
outcome the potential of it so
first is team i want to meet the team if
i if i check the box on team smart guys
good engineers good strategy good group
i'm interested here's the test the
second test
what economic value are they creating in
the case of polygon let's stay on that
polygon for a second aggregating
transactions to reduce gas fees on each
is a smart idea there's a reason you
would do that because you have an
economic reason to pursue that you save
money transaction fees are less so i
think the potential of that is large
hbar okay great team good engineers
what's the economic premise that would
keep that
growing well boeing wants a
quasi-centralized decentralized platform
they want the best of both worlds hbar
can deliver that check the box there buy
into that one too
look what's going on with you know
solana
i mean they're trying to solve problems
a different way too speed everything up
check the box who's working on that sam
bank and freight on his team why
wouldn't you bet that horse so it's all
about getting positions in all of these
you know
software platforms that's what they are
they're software platforms so i i say
institutions you you're you criticize me
for investing in bitcoin you own a big
position microsoft you own a five
percent waiting in yahoo what is that
that's software why don't you do the
same thing in bitcoin why don't you do
the same thing in ethereum why aren't
you an h bar why aren't you polygon why
aren't you in serum why aren't you in
helium like it's all software
and so with with that attitude on it's
hard to say i'll only invest in publicly
traded software companies one day these
to me and i really believe this one day
crypto and all these software platforms
are going to be the 12th sector of the s
p and i'm just taking the bet now that
we're on our way there and i'm taking
and staking my bets now
broad portfolio you know no one ethereum
is my biggest position right now
bitcoin's had a bit of a correction i
get it but there's been volatility
but now
to offset that volatility i own an
exchange
so i want to own more exchanges
i look at it it's all software
johnson kevin yeah thanks for coming on
you talk about um this industry being
the 12th sector of the s p and recently
jerome powell said that their report on
crypto and cbdc's are coming is coming
out soon what are your thoughts on the
impact that that report can have and
what do you think that report will
contain
i'm encouraged by that report because it
shows that they're inching forward and
they're trying to do it right i my
opinion about the regulator is they're
they understand the tremendous potential
of this technology the potential of you
know streamlined payment systems the
potential productivity
that
blockchain has in smart contracts and
and all the use the case uses for it
they get it but at the same time they're
well aware that when they rule it will
be the global standard the chinese
aren't going to do this no one's going
to follow them they're going to follow
the sec they're going to follow the u.s
regulator so they want to get it right
the first place i would like them to get
it right would be on the baseline stable
coin as a payment system i would very
very much like to be able to transact
globally
pick a coin my preference is usdc but
pick one
regulate it and let me as a investor
along with hundreds of millions of other
investors
use it as a form of payment and
stability it would be fantastic it was
backed by the us dollar they know that
they know that
it would be just be so much more
efficient and so
you know so less expensive if i could
just transact maintain a centralized
decentralized wallet um and just be able
to imagine if i could buy a swiss stock
with a stable coin instead of having to
go us dollar into swiss franc
buy the security then back into swiss
franc back in the us dollar you know how
screwed i get doing that how much hot
friction there is and how much i lose
it's insane same with euro stocks same
with british pounds same with canadian
dollars i mean i invest in all these
jurisdictions and i have to deal with
that
and so it's sort of that's where i think
we want to go first once they rule on
that everybody will say okay we're
moving in that direction
it'll be very constructive for the asset
allocation you talked about at the
beginning of the hour on institutional
follow-through into crypto there's no
question you're right there's a lot of
demand they just need the regulator on
board
kevin what's interesting about that idea
is basically the us dollar if it does
get kind of the blessing right i think a
lot about like the uh the regulators are
essentially the pope at this point right
they're just gonna give the blessing to
the stable coins especially things like
usdc etc uh when that happens there's
not a lot of reason for people to go
back into the antiquated technologies of
the same currency so we just have
physical dollars now we have what's
called an electronic dollar which is in
a centralized database with uh kind of
uh long settlement times to eventually
you just move to the digital version and
so monetary policy doesn't change just a
new technology upgrade if that was to
happen do you think that the other
currencies around the world would suffer
and what i mean by that is if you have
us dollars rather than be forced to go
into swiss francs before you go and buy
a stock now you're just going to go
straight from usdc into the stock do
some of these weaker currencies and
maybe not in developed nations
especially in like developing countries
they start to suffer at the hands
of the more dominant fiat currencies or
how do you think about that
yeah the way i look at it is there's
going to be
um
four or five currencies that will be
digitized so there will be a digital
version of the swiss franc there will be
a digital version of the euro there will
be a digital version of the british
pound there'll be a digital version of
the canadian dollar
there'll be a digital version of the us
dollar it may be a stable coin in that
case but the reason i think that happens
is you allow the economies to compete
with each other on productivity and
interest rates so that if i'm going to
go buy something in switzerland there'll
be a spot exchange price from my usdc or
whatever the stablecoin is into the
stable version of the swiss franc and i
may elect to keep a portfolio
as i do today of multiple currencies
because basically
i want to own swiss francs that country
is very very efficient it's a very good
currency they don't have a lot of debt
so how do i own the digital version of
that because
right now if you want to own native
swiss francs
you practically can't do it because if
you want to open an account in
switzerland as an american citizen you
can't you can't do it they won't open it
for you
i think all of this
political
border stuff goes away with digitization
of the currency so i'm very optimistic
for that now the reason you'd only have
four or five of them
chinese one yeah that's going to be
digital at some point but i own a
chinese one probably not if the
government's watching
you know my wallet address and it'll be
an unfavored currency for that reason
but i'd happily own swiss francs happily
own the digital american dollar
it'll it's going to play itself out but
you said you're saying you know
if it happens
100 is going to happen it's just when
the efficient if just if if we just
digitize our dollar or we got a stable
dollar like a bank if circle became a
bank i don't need anything else
i'll just
own that and i'll piece it off
digitally whenever i need to buy some
some other kind of asset
and i'll be staking it at whatever the
current rate is i'll be rolling my
contracts and just like in the old days
when you could make five six percent
interest which you don't get anymore and
so i think there's a really big use case
and why there's so much pressure on the
regulator to rule on this thing and you
guys are dead right
the efficiency brought forward is just
insane it's so powerful an economic
reason to pursue this agreed last
question then we'll let you get back to
uh miami beach you know get a little tan
going because it's 70 something degrees
here for anyone who's stuck in new york
at 12 degree weather uh is um when you
think about your portfolio i think
previously you were kind of
two three four percent you had
aspirations but not quite at i think it
was like eight percent nine percent
somewhere in that range is what you were
kind of targeting and eventually you
said that you could see going up to like
20
in uh in a single sector uh but that
would take some time to get there where
are you today and how have your thoughts
around uh kind of portfolio allocation
percentages how has that changed since
last time we talked
at year end last year we thought we'd be
at seven where we were at 10.7
percent in the operating company
portfolio and today i just this morning
i got off with
our our compliance guys um because of
our recent investments uh additional
investments in some of the equities that
we bought
i increased my position in hold
immutable holdings the jordan freed
company that owns nft.com
i bought more of that and i also bought
a lot more of on the deal of uh the
wonder if i did buying blockchain or by
bit by
we're now
today at um
16.5 percent
and so we're on our way to 20 and it
happened really really fast
and i'm comfortable with it it's more
volatile than our traditional book
because when you look at what else we
own it's you know commercial real estate
it's large cap uh s p cu companies
dividend payers a lot of them
this stuff is volatile but the
underlying potential and the growth of
it
um and i i know that a lot of
institutions are going through the the
angst i'm having
i can't find better opportunities than
these companies like they are
really this is like investing in the
earliest days of the internet the
earliest days
because we're in the first inning of
this stuff and so you you got you have
to find your opportunities
where they are and and
you know
probably by the end of this quarter i'm
going to be at 20
that's what's happening here
so
i think i've said this to you before uh
on the show but if not
in 2018
you forbid me it was garbage the whole
nine yards i knew i knew before the day
was over you're gonna bring that up
again hold on hold on this is a
compliment though but
from there to essentially let's call it
three years later or less so within
three years
from that perspective which actually i
will uh admit was a fair perspective for
most people to have at the time because
they had just watched bitcoin go from
twenty thousand fall to three uh
thousand dollars etc
to now have sixteen percent of your
portfolio in the industry and not only
have what i'll call like true skin in
the game and in a growing percentage but
to be able to talk about it with such
detailed nuance the understanding of the
regulatory side the technology etc
i got to say kudos man i'm very
impressed i i think that you not only
understand what's happening here but uh
you're kind of not sitting back letting
it you know
like pass by you you're jumping into it
and i think there's a lot of people who
you would consider your peers that they
may say okay yeah he's probably not
wrong but like let's figure out what to
do let's go read some white papers
whatever and they're gonna take another
two years before they jump in and
they're just gonna miss a huge piece of
this so it's not only the the
willingness to change your mind and all
that but it's also the the courage and
conviction to kind of act in a way that
sixteen percent like that's not gonna
sneeze your nose at especially because
you have these like weird rules like no
more than twenty percent uh uh single
sector no more than five percent in a
single stock it's you know it's like
almost like i know all your talking
points on that stuff
yeah no you're right but that is the way
the mandates work out there globally and
sovereign and pension everything else
you know it's sort of um one of the
challenges i've got is i have to include
uh
my my holdings and my contracts on usdc
as basically an equity as i said earlier
which to me is frustrating um because
i would i you know i can't get past 20
but it should be treated like what it is
it's a it's a currency where there are
no rules like that but we're not there
yet and it's it's a push i i will say
one thing in closing watch what happens
this year in the amount of capital that
comes into that new mining model
that
we're going to solve this csg problem in
2022 you're going to see
a lot of institutional capital come into
this idea of mining within a community
supporting a community doing an esg
compliant ethically compliant all that
stuff and they'll own the equity just
like they own any other equity but
they'll be exposed to the vol of bitcoin
that's how they're going to do it yeah i
i think that uh
i think that people are underestimating
how uh violently institutional capital
moves when it moves uh we saw this with
bitcoin in um 2020 into 2021 uh there
was really a lot of the price was driven
by uh the arbitrage for the grayscale
bitcoin trust i mean there was just
massive capital inflows there uh and
because that capital couldn't be
redeemed uh there ended up being this
huge price increase at one point i think
grayscale was buying like 150 of all
bitcoin being mined every day right so
it's just they were just sucking
liquidity out of the market and that was
just institutional capital and it
frankly wasn't the big boys it was hedge
funds and family offices etc
i do think that once
the really really large firms whether
it's the sovereign wealth the you know
large trillion dollar asset managers etc
when they start to allocate you know i
mean if you really think about it right
now if a trillion dollar asset manager
said we're gonna go put 100 allocation
of bitcoin
they could buy from a price concept all
the bitcoin that is liquid traded on the
market now of course they can't actually
get because someone's going to sell it
to them but like they have enough money
to buy the entire market cap and so i
think people just they don't understand
how much money these people have and how
quickly i i agree with your analysis
what happened there that was not healthy
for the market i prefer more
transparency more liquidity and i think
we're going to get it through you know
massive amounts of
of capital going into the equity of
miners that's the way it's going to
first manifest itself and that'll have
much more liquidity much more
transparency much more disclosure and
it'll be compliant it's i think it's a
trade of 2022 i think you're going to
see a bunch of deals announced a lot of
them in west texas i'm aware of a lot of
these deals and certainly looking at
them and i'm planning on investing in
some of them so i can make claim to
owning direct esg compliant coin and
that's what every other institution
wants to do if you like that video where
did you see my next one don't forget to
click right over here and subscribe